my name is Rob Crosley and I know a
little bit about Marvel the universe who
are a few films seen a few comics and
read them but I saw them Dogma symbol
the title says the Mighty Thor so I'm
gonna say for safety shot did it work
I know this one yep Groot I think I know
this interesting Magneto that is not
Magnus all I can see you is the thing
ski mask
mascara all right that was [ __ ] yeah but
I'm going for is my first dance ago
stick to it steal a smoke mast
that's what you'd think
cyclone Cyclops weakened shaft as a
Slimer oh I have no idea
could it be man-bat that is black wing
yeah I want to say it okay spider-man
that is pox in son of carnage you
basically just trolled me then you know
I get I like Robert Downey jr. mmhmm yep
he is in that movie and he is Iron Man
that is war machine so missus lollipop
from lollipop I don't know free they are
Kill Bill 1
and killable 3 you really need to work
on your Marvel Comics knowledge I have
someone read on them
you've probably won't like it but I work